[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 après l'année
européenne de la jeunesse la Commission
européenne souhaite mettre en avant les
talents et les compétences de 2023 sera
donc l'année européenne des talents pour
en parler avec nous je suis aujourd'hui
avec Marie Raphaël minier manager du
Centre Europe Direct à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye bonjour bonjour
alors la Maison de l'Europe des Yvelines
est le Centre Europe Direct travail
ensemble tout au long de l'année pour
monter des projets autour de l'Europe et
des thématiques européennes le Centre
Europe Direct a été inauguré fin 2021 si
je me trompe pas à Saint-Germain-en-Laye
quelles sont les objectifs justement sur
le territoire de Saint-Quentin des
Yvelines pardon alors les objectifs
globaux d'un Centre Europe Direct c'est
vraiment le rapprochement physique
et aussi idéologique en quelque sorte
entre l'Europe et les citoyens c'est à
dire faire redescendre des directives
parfois un peu confuse ou un peu
lointaines de Bruxelles ou de Strasbourg
pour les habitants de de notre zone donc
les Yvelines en l'occurrence mais aussi
faire remonter de la part des habitants
de ces zones des préoccupations des
inquiétudes des remarques aux personnes
qui travaillent à la Commission
européenne et plus précisément à la
représentation en France de la
Commission européenne qui est à Paris
donc votre rôle c'est vraiment
finalement le rôle d'informateur et
également de sensibilisation auprès des
citoyens tout à fait alors lorsque le
l'Europe met en place un projet un vous
l'avez dit ou adopte une proposition
vous êtes là pour donc informer les
citoyens des de ses décisions vous
mettez également différents projets en
place en lien avec l'Union européenne en
2023 ça sera l'année européenne des
talents pourquoi se tourner vers les
compétences les talents des citoyens
alors en fait ça a été un des fer de
lance du discours sur l'état de l'Union
l'éternel discours annuel d'Ursula
vanderlion qui en fait s'est basé sur un
constat très simple c'est que suite à la
crise sanitaire liée à la pandémie de
covid-19 on note que trois quarts des
entreprises ont du mal à recruter alors
que les compétences sont là parfois
méconnues des gens eux-mêmes des jeunes
eux-mêmes et surtout que certains
secteur notamment les secteurs
scientifiques sont encore des réservés
aux hommes les métiers d'hommes donc la
Commission européenne a dit voilà on va
faire des focus sur les talents les
compétences réelles des gens pour que
les entreprises peinent moins recruter
des forces vives alors cette année
européenne des compétences des talents
découlent de plusieurs constats que vous
avez noté justement dans un communiqué
de presse trois quarts des entreprises
disent avoir des difficultés à trouver
des travailleurs possédants les
compétences nécessaires un tiers des
personnes travaillant en Europe ne
disposent pas de compétences numériques
de base et autres constats la
représentation vous l'avez évoqué des
femmes dans les professions liées aux
technologies avec un sixième de femmes
dans ce domaine est-ce qu'il fallait
donc agir et agir vite absolument parce
que une femme sur six spécialisée dans
l'informatique quand on voit les besoins
à l'heure de la transition numérique
c'est pas possible
et surtout c'est de coopérer avec et les
États membres et le Parlement européen
pour Prom pouvoir des investissements
plus efficaces pour aider les gens soit
à passer d'un emploi à un autre soit à
se reconvertir et par exemple alors une
femme puisqu'on en parlait qui aurait
commencé des études de commerce ou qui
visait un poste dans l'enseignement va
se dire bah non en fait moi j'ai
toujours voulu faire de l'informatique
on m'a dit que c'était pas un métier de
femme voilà ce que je peux faire donc
déjà déconstruire finalement cette idée
que il n'y a pas de métier qui est
réservé aux hommes et aux femmes
complètement et il y a du coup dans les
deux constats ce numérique vous l'avez
dit l'évolution numérique la transition
vers le numérique ça devient aussi une
étape importante en tant que en tant que
citoyen européen de se tourner aussi
vers des formations numériques oui tout
à fait sachant qu'en plus un des un des
autres programmes phares de cette année
c'est ce qu'on a appelé la transition
verte et numérique inclusive alors ça
fait beaucoup de mots
mais le numérique oui mes propres donc
en prenant attention aux données à la
pollution que ça peut générer et à la
façon dont on forme les gens
et oui les formations à distance ont
pris aussi beaucoup le pas sur les
formations en présentiel quels sont les
solutions apportées par la Commission
européenne pour finalement donner un
nouvel élan justement à cette à cet
apprentissage alors déjà essayez de
faciliter le déplacement de personnes
d'un pays à l'autre de l'Union
européenne pour occuper un poste indiqué
en faisant en sorte que le niveau de
diplôme ou de langue ne soit plus
réellement même si c'est très compliqué
dans la pratique un réel barrage donc
c'est proposé aux gens des formations
pour qu'ils puissent aller travailler
dans un autre pays comblé certains
besoins ce sera dans l'informatique ce
sera dans la restauration
ce sera même dans le secteur médical
mais ce sera voilà une facilitation
des échanges humains il y aura aussi une
grosse part de l'agence Erasmus plus qui
va mettre en place ce qu'on a appelé le
programme Alma qui n'a pas encore vu le
jour mais qui va arriver donc breaking
news et qui va proposer un Erasmus pour
les gens réellement en difficulté
scolaire
et alors justement moi je voudrais
revenir sur sur les langues vous avez
dit normalement aujourd'hui ça ne
devrait plus être une barrière il y a
énormément de personnes qui ont des
lacunes justement dans les langues c'est
nouveau justement d'apprentissages
pourraient permettre finalement de de de
comment dire de combattre un petit peu
c'est lacunes en partant à l'étranger
oui absolument sachant que toute
personne quel que soit son niveau de
compétence de base qui participent à un
programme Erasmus que ce soit pour les
jeunes pour les étudiants pour les
apprenants pour les stagiaires de la
formation professionnelle ou pour les
adultes et mise en place une plateforme
numérique de cours de langue ou l'accès
est illimité où on peut noter sa
progression dans la langue de la
mobilité la langue dont on va avoir
besoin donc ça c'est déjà un pas qui est
très important et la Commission
européenne a également mis en place le
pacte pour les compétences qui
s'adressent ce pacte à toutes les
personnes peu ou pas diplômées qui vont
souhaiter
se réorienter ou se s'orienter vers un
métier un des métiers dont on parler
tout à l'heure et qui peine pour
l'instant à recruter donc ça c'est les
objectifs encore une fois c'est de
pousser de toute façon vers
l'apprentissage vers la formation
absolument comment allez-vous procéder
justement tout au long de l'année quels
sont les actions que vous allez mettre
en place pour sensibiliser justement les
Yvelinois à cette année européenne des
talents alors on essaye beaucoup aussi
d'être présent sur tout ce qui est forum
premier job job d'été orientation
présence dans les établissements
scolaires pour expliquer que l'Europe la
mobilité européenne ce n'est pas réservé
à une élite détentrice d'un certain
niveau de diplôme de type master donc ça
c'est une première chose et c'est aussi
montrer que la mobilité européenne est
proposée à des filières qu'on imaginait
pas tout le monde pense au semestre
Erasmus qu'on fait quand on est en
licence de psycho ou en master
d'économie mais pas forcément à 15 jours
dans un établissement agricole quand on
étudie la co-culture à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye
ou un stage d'observation dans un
restaurant à Berlin quand on décide
soi-même de se ré orienter vers la
cuisine donc c'est vraiment mettre
l'accent là dessus de plus en plus ça
veut dire orienter nos propres mobilités
vers ce genre de secteur en essayant de
trouver des partenaires sur place dans
les pays d'accueil qui nous prennent des
jeunes dans la restauration dans
l'informatique dans la santé ou dans
l'accompagnement par exemple aux
personnes âgées
ça va être beaucoup de communication
enfin sur nos réseaux sociaux et sur le
site internet pour vraiment montrer tout
le panel que propose la Commission
européenne alors justement j'aimerais
vraiment qu'on synthétise ou en tout cas
qu'on insiste là dessus Erasmus plus ce
n'est pas seulement réservé aux
personnes qui font des études
supérieures pas du tout on peut y aller
que ce soit même collège donc pour un
stage d'apprentissage lycée voilà lycée
et des publics qui ont des difficultés
etc c'est tout à fait possible
absolument et sans limite d'âge sans
restriction façon limite au niveau des
diplômes sans restriction au niveau de
l'âge et avec une possibilité
d'accompagnement pour les personnes en
ayant besoin des personnes porteuses de
handicap
qu'ils soient visuel moteur etc ou qui
ait besoin d'un aménagement du temps de
travail mais vous suivez également la
Stratégie Europe 2030 qui se concentre
sur la formation des adultes pour
atteindre un taux d'emploi de 78% d'ici
2030 l'emploi et la formation sont de
thématiques importantes et qui inquiète
les citoyens européens finalement la
réponse de l'Union européenne face à ces
difficultés de recrutement de formation
ou d'égalité est-elle suffisante selon
vous est-ce que la Commission européenne
pourrait aller encore un peu plus loin
alors pour moi elle est
je peux pas réellement dire qu'elle est
insuffisante
on va voir déjà ce qui va se passer en
2023 et 6 tous les dispositifs mis
autour d'un nom très global l'Année
européenne des talents porte leur fruit
sur le plan pratique si vraiment il y a
des gens qui osent franchir le pas si
vraiment les jeunes sentent leur
capacité
d'aller plus loin de partir en mobilité
ou tout simplement de se réorienter ou
de reprendre leurs études après je pense
comme toujours et c'est aussi le rôle
des Europe Direct qu'il faut vraiment
porter sur le terrain cette année
européenne des compétences sinon les
gens vont nous dire mais oui mais tout
le monde a des compétences et tout le
monde est capable mais qu'est-ce qu'on
fait concrètement et pour l'Année
européenne des compétences les États
membres peuvent également obtenir un
financement de la part de l'Union
européenne quelles sont ses financements
possibles alors il va y avoir le fond
social européen ou également appelé FSE
plus qui va être le principal instrument
de l'Union européenne pour investir dans
les ressources semaine le programme pour
une Europe numérique qui va quand même
être dotée de 580 millions d'euros et le
programme Horizon Europe qui va soutenir
les chercheurs les innovateurs et les
auto-entrepreneurs on peut retrouver
plus d'informations sur votre site
maison Europe 78.eu rubrique Centre
Europe Direct on en reparlera également
dans d'autres émissions tout au long de
tout au long de l'année merci beaucoup
rafale Marie Raphaël minier d'avoir été
avec nous sur sensation et pour revoir
ou réécouter cette émission rendez-vous
sur notre site et notre application
radio sensation
[Musique]